this is a clinically insane hypothesis  that this person has and if they were to  sit down with a psychiatrist i believe  they would be medicated for presenting  what this person presents in this video  take a look at this i got a good idea  what's going on in ukraine when they  went into ukraine and they found these  labs  they believed that made that the  deep state  is  possibly going to use a bio weapon on  russian people because they've been just  like that they were collecting our dna  in china they've been collecting their  dna as well okay so  chinese dna collection is analogous to  something that the deep state is going  to do  to then bio-weapon the russian  population  wow i mean  this is someone whose brain is  mayonnaise